la lutte contre la fraude de nouvel
enjeux de taille pour la région
Île-de-France aujourd'hui la SNCF la
RATP et le STIF représenté par Valérie
Pécresse ont tenu conjointement une
conférence de presse pour annoncer le
lancement d'une grande campagne de
communication intitulée fraudeur pour
vous les règles ont changé elle vise à
rappeler aux usagers le durcissement des
sanctions à l'encontre des fraudeurs
depuis la promulgation en mars de la loi
Savary le roue des amandes plus élevés
et plus d'outils pour les agents que
vous allez le voir
la chasse aux fraudeurs est lancée avec
la promulgation de la loi DITES LE ROUX
Savary du 22 mars 2016 et inspiré des
propositions de Valérie Pécresse le
cadre se durcit pour les fraudeurs en
2015 la RATP a comptabilisé 1,5 millions
d'infractions 510 000 pour Transilien
moi je prends des tout le temps
je me savais pas attraper mais bon c'est
pas trop risqué de frauder parce que il
y a pas de temps que ça de contrôleur
dans les bus donc au final non c'est pas
risqué frauder et pas si risqué les
transporteurs veulent prouver le
contraire la loi le ou sa varie punit
déjà la déclaration de fausses identité
de deux mois d'emprisonnement et de 3750
euros d'amende
le délit dit d'habitude lui est relevé
plus de 5 infractions sur une année et
le fraudeur s'expose à 6 mois
d'emprisonnement et 7500 euros d'amende
d'autres dispositions entreront en
vigueur prochainement aujourd'hui les
personnels de la RATP de la SNCF sont
tous assermentés pour contrôler et on
pourra aussi avoir des patrouilles en
civils de sécurité sur le réseau RATP
sur le réseau SNCF la loi a changé et ça
va devenir beaucoup plus difficile de
frauder et surtout ça va être beaucoup
plus pénalisant parce que si vous allez
quelque part et qu'on vous retient
plusieurs heures pour que vous prouviez
votre identité et bien ce sera difficile
des mesures censées faciliter le travail
des agents sur le terrain c'est de
communiquer sur ce nouveau délit de
faire savoir que ce serait au contrôle
peut entraîner une peine de prison une
peine d'amende importante évidemment un
effet dysphasie on aura toujours besoin
d'un renfort mais c'est vrai que vous
avez beaucoup de voyageurs qui ne
présent pas leur pièce d'identité qui ne
veulent pas la présenter et c'est vrai
que c'est assez accidentogène chaque
année la RATP consacre 1250 agents et 90
millions d'euros à la lutte contre la
fraude pour le STIF la RATP et la région
Île de France l'enjeu est avant tout
financier nous avons demandé à la RATP
de faire 20 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires supplémentaires grâce à la
lutte contre la fraude et à la CNCF de
faire 10 millions c'est des objectifs
très ambitieux en 2015 la Cour des
comptes a évalué à 366 millions d'euros
le coût de la fraude en Île-de-France